قراران اتخذتهما حركه طالبان الاول بمنع
الفتيات من التعليم والاخر بمنعهن من
العمل مع المنظمات الانسانيه الدوليه
اسهاما بموجه غضب عربيه دوليه واسلاميه
المجتمع الدولي يعتبر ان قرارات الحركه
اعاده افغانستان سنوات الى الوراء ليس
اجتماعيا فحسب بل حتى اقتصاديا ومعيشيا اذ
اوقفت العديد من المنظمات الانسانيه
اعمالها في البلاد اذا اوقفت فعلا فهذا
الوقف سيكون له بالغ الاثر على الافغان
الذين يعانون اساسا من اوضاع اقتصاديه
تعيسه كانت تلك المنظمات رافدا ومساعدا
يسد رمق العوز الذي يعصف بالشعب الافغاني
خطوه طالبان اثارت ولا تزال ردود فعل
دوليه عاصفه اذا عقدت الامم المتحده جلسه
احاطه طلبها منسق المنظمه الدوليه للشؤون
الانسانيه
المتحده وقفه او ان الامم المتحده ترت الى
وقف بعض البرامج والمساعدات في افغانستان
مؤقتا كرد على طالبان هو الذي اعلن وحذر
من ان العديد من الانشطه الاخرى ستتوقف
على الارجح المنسق الاممي اضاف في بيان ان
الامم المتحده لا يمكنها تجاهل القيود
التشغيليه التي تواجه المجتمع الانساني في
افغانستان مشيرا الى ان المنظمه الدوليه
ستسعى لمواصله الانشطه المنقذه للحياه
[موسيقى]
بدورها
الطالبان الى الالغاء العاجل لحضري عمل
النساء في المنظمات غير الحكوميه وفق ما
جاء في بيان المشترك نشرته وزاره الخارجيه
البريطانيه
قالوا انهم قلقون بشده لان امر طالبان
متهور والخطير بمنع الموظفات النساء من
العمل في المنظمات غير الحكوميه الوطنيه
ورفاهيه الشعب الافغاني خصوصا النساء
والفتيات عربي
منظمه التعاون الاسلامي حسين ابراهيم طه
الذي دعا الى موقف جماعي بشان قرار طالبان
منع الفتيات من التعليم الجامعي طه دعم
مجمع الفقه الاسلامي الدوليه الى حشد موقف
من الم تحياتي كافه والعلماء المسلمين من
قرار طالبان ضد تعليم الفتيات وصفا القرار
بانه يعتبر احدث التحديات التي يواجهها
المجمع وشدد طه على اولويه الملف الافغاني
في اجندات عمل المنظمه والمجمع مشيرا الى
ان قرار طالبان لا يستند الى نصوص في
الشريعه الاسلاميه
المتحدث باسمي اتحاد الجامعه الخاصه في
افغانستان محمد كريم مصير قال ان ربع
الجامعات الخاصه في افغانستان تواجه خطر
الاغلاق بسبب الحظر المفروض على الطالبات
من قبل حكومه طالبان
[موسيقى]